if you're like the estimated 74
of adults in the us who use youtube this
might be what your home screen looks
like
an algorithmically curated look into
what you like to watch
maybe some tips on how to prepare a new
meal or your favorite vlogger's latest
video
but if you're a parent who shares your
phone with your children it probably
looks a little more like this
kids content on youtube is huge views
for videos can reach into the billions
5 of the top 10 videos in all of
youtube's history
are either music videos or kids videos
with baby shark having more views than
people on the planet
[Music]
youtube has created a revolution
not an evolution in
the way kids and families consume video
content
and that extends then into
how they view toys and play and
all of the associated things that go
with that his youtube for the unaware
can be adorable
it can be boring
it can also just be flat out strange
here i
am here i am how do you do
but often it involves toys and for toy
makers who embrace the platform
it led to record success and i think
hello
surprise unquestionably is the biggest
phenomenon that has
ever happened in toy industry this is
the story of how youtube
changed kids toys
play patterns the way children play
is timeless but how we deliver
on those play patterns through product
and how we market that to children has
changed
quite a bit over the years and i would
say that
the last five to ten years really ranks
right up there
with the 1950s when tv commercials
directed to children
was first launched by mattel this is
nancy's weirs
she led the barbie brand during the 90s
and spent four years as the chief
marketing officer for spin master
it used to be that there would be a few
play things that
parents would bring into the home or
that children would create themselves
like a stick and a ball
becomes a play thing and the industry
was at a certain level
of volume at that point mattel was
very innovative and actually put the
first product on tv
and advertised it to children let's play
house
this created a huge explosion
in the toy industry that unfolded across
decades
the hit of the day when you're ready to
play everyone knows this blinks
here he comes here he comes greatest toy
you've ever seen
and his name is
when you go back to the 1980s what do
you think of in terms of hit shows
you think of things like masters of the
universe you think of the original
transformers
and care bears the joke was they were 22
minute commercials
just close your eyes and care
let's make a tv show which is really
promotion for our property or ip
to help sell toys there are a lot of
those famous characters in which
kids absolutely loved it they were
totally entertained
but there were huge toy lines behind
them this is jim silver
a 37-year veteran of the toys industry
in 1999 he started a consumer toy review
magazine called toy wishes
and now he's the ceo of an influencer
talent management group
ttpm regulations changed through the
years
and also parents became aware that they
were purely commercials
and you saw a lot of the new channels
the disney channel and nickelodeon they
realized that wouldn't work anymore
and to them entertainment came before
licensing what happened over time
was that toys started to become designed
for a 30-second commercial closed it's a
mild matter toolbox open it's a micro
machine usa cruiser mini micro machine
vehicles planes opposed to the police
station the marina the mini motorcycle
repair shop gas station the construction
office work the real work and drawbridge
highway passenger wrapping garage doors
so if you couldn't explain it in a
30-second commercial
cost reduce it out of the product and
just uh stick with
you know what you could say and features
of toys
magical features using electronics
lights and sounds and mechanical
movements that
magic like they don't know how it
happens that became more and more
important
the sound of power is
see ya heard batman's turbo powered
batmobile flies into high gear
since 2000 with uh cable channels
dedicated to kids
disney channel nickelodeon cartoon
network
there became the opportunity to reach
kids in
mass numbers every day of the week
and so the the toy industries continued
to grow
the toy industry for the most part was a
pretty solid business just you know
growing a couple percent a year here and
there
there'd be big big years here and there
when there's maybe a hit movie
like a star wars movie come out you know
drive a lot of toy sales
from 2014 to 2019 the global toy
industry would grow
by 15 at about the same time
those major cable networks of
nickelodeon disney channel and cartoon
network
would lose half their total audience
2017 also saw the bankruptcy of toys r
us
as both parents and kids discovered and
bought more toys
online if you think about kids they're
usually the first adopters of a new
medium kids weren't watching things like
nickelodeon as much as they used to they
were watching
things on youtube youtube started in
early 2005
uh and this was like you know the very
early web 2.0 this beginning
of sort of like uh what what the time
was convenience user generated content
like web blogging was really big myspace
was the biggest thing
on the internet back then there was an
early video of a brazilian soccer legend
um doing stunt tricks that just uh when
it
exploded on the site one of the first
viral videos lazy sunday if you remember
that snl
short chronicles
you remember those early viral hits
youtube in the early days
was definitely comedy and music
it was a place of experimentation i was
the
chief audience officer at maker studios
i
oversaw essentially the creator
partnerships
all over the world maker studios was one
of the largest multi-channel networks on
youtube
and had partnered with some of the
biggest youtube channels of the time
before being sold to disney in 2014.
chris is now the ceo of pocket watch
which represents some of the largest
kids stars on youtube including ryan's
world
and love diana who can amass over a
couple billion views every month
the truth is one of the very biggest and
earliest videos
on all of youtube is by a creator and
star named ijustine
where she unboxed her first
mobile phone bill for her brand new
iphone and it came in a box and
this ultimately morphed into many
different
formats associated with unboxing and
tech
was actually really big and those became
fairly successful
um pretty early on on the platform
and you know you saw them expand from
tech products to beauty products uh and
then
around 2012 and 2013 we saw this
explosion
uh into toys so here's the furby inside
right here
we used to call them hands channels okay
and a hands channel was literally
a top-down view of someone's hands
unboxing typically a toy and they'd
unbox it
they'd show each component we just got
uncle scrooge i would speak to many of
those creators we
signed many of those creators at maker
studios to be our partners
and it was it was fascinating in that
it was this whole new genre and this
whole new format
and that corresponded
with a rise of kids and family
viewership on youtube that was stark
that was hard to miss and you would see
it in the data
and we had access to a lot of data maker
studios around youtube
let's see what's inside first up we have
the stormtrooper pig
you saw the launch of evantube who i
consider the first
child so to speak unboxing star
and they would open toys and kids were
just mesmerized by it
they loved watching it and next thing
you know you had
literally 50 unboxings they were
unboxing just about every toy
you know it was and people were just
really excited you opened the toy
and you see a toy pop out and kids just
got excited seeing it piece by piece
yeah he's he's in a bathrobe wearing a
he's eating a lobster
you know the early days of these
unboxing videos the videos were you know
from adults perspective just terrible i
mean they were 10 minutes long
they were boring there was a shaky
camera there was
absolutely no production value and if
you think about these executives you
know they're
they're trying to figure out how to
reach this new audience and they're
they're brought these videos and say
well look at this video it has
200 000 views on it and it's terrible
when i first heard of it i thought it
was the weirdest thing it just seemed
kind of bizarre
who would want to watch someone opening
a toy taking it out of the box
but then when i started thinking about
this idea of exploration and discovery
as a core play pattern
the most fundamental play pattern there
is
it it started to make sense and i think
that
um i have to say that the company that
that
really jumped on that in the most
concerted way
was mga with their launch of lol
[Music]
surprise ll surprise had three key
elements
uh doll play which is you know basically
the most popular
play pattern there is collectible so
with within each lol surprise you'd get
a little sheet that showed you all the
other dolls you could collect
and then the surprise factor you didn't
know which doll you were getting it was
a blind pack
as they call it and lol was made by this
company
called mga back then you know 2016 they
were a
small player in the toy industry founded
by
this guy named isaac larian he's the ceo
and founder i have three adult kids and
they were making fun of me
that oh you're old you don't know
anything about what's happening
in today's thing and i said like what
and they said for example that
is do you know about this iphone
unboxing videos that get
millions and millions of views so i
thought they're pulling my leg
the children do to make fun of their
parents
and then i did go and look one night
and i was frankly shocked and
flabbergasted that
why would you why would anybody buy an
iphone take it home
and open the box and show it on the
camera
and everybody will go and watch it so i
typed
toy unboxing and my god i saw
so many different videos and
people kids and adults buying toys like
an
apple and uh unboxing it and video and
posting it
so that gave me an idea that why not
come up with the ultimate uh and that's
that's the first lol surprise all right
oh
yes we've got a gold ball lol
changed the way you open with toys and
everybody saw that and the packaging
became part of the play
which became part of the entertainment
so normally
if you get a package that you just open
a package you take the toy out that's
not exciting
you open up lol you peel it away you
open up inside
you have seven surprises and it took off
like wildfire
and quickly became you know the top toy
in the country
by december of 2018 eight of the top ten
toys sold were all
lol surprise brand and according to mga
from 2016 to 2020
lol would generate over 10 billion
dollars in retail sales worldwide
you know ll is bigger than star wars
it's bigger than marvel
it's bigger than barbie these brands
with huge advertising budgets
are known basically by everyone you
don't have to you know
figure out what marble or star wars is
and lol
eclipsed them all in the toy world blind
bag or blind box toys have been growing
in popularity
the most famous example in recent years
is pokemon cards where you open packs in
hopes of getting a charizard but more
often wind up with something common like
gligar here
two years before the launch of lol in
2014
the australian toy company moose toys
launched a blind bag collectible called
shopkins and in 2016 spin master would
launch a more expensive blind box toy it
called
hatchimals
[Music]
but the thing that sets lol surprise
apart is that it mainly focused
on youtube and not putting ads on
youtube but working with creators and
influencers
to get their products in the hands of
these kids doing the unboxing videos
for mga actually the move towards
youtube was
was kind of a bit lucky and almost out
of necessity in late 2015
nickelodeon parent company viacom would
sue mga for breach of contract
after it failed to pay 3.5 million
dollars for the production of a tv
series based on their lalaloopsy dolls
they tried to flex their muscle and they
said
well if you don't agree to
our way of seeing things in the conflict
that we had a separate conflict
we are going to stop your advertisement
of toys at the time nickelodeon was the
number one
ranked children's network and not to be
able to advertise in nickelodeon could
have been
a death now but mga
necessity is the mother of invention
that caused them to lean into digital
advertising
far more than any big brand had ever
done before
because they had to they had to find a
new way to reach
kids the court would ultimately rule in
favor of viacom
both in la federal court and on appeal
in the ninth circuit
larian blamed the court defeat on what
he contends was judicial bias
nickelodeon parent company viacom didn't
respond to a request for comment
so that by itself forced us to go and
say okay
the hell with nickelodeon let's find
another way to reach
to children and that's how we went
and doubled up on youtube especially
and the rest as they say is history
so early on mga partnered with youtube
creators with
huge audiences like cookie swirl c good
morning chocolaty chippy cookies we are
gonna be spending the morning with this
lol surprise baby fancy
they took it another step further they
actually helped kids learn how to do
their
own unboxing videos they they gave them
you know support and learning and tools
and so all these kids got to be
kind of a little mini influencer
themselves as they were unboxing their
lol
products so just to give you a flavor of
how popular these videos are
go on to youtube and search lol surprise
and you'll see videos with a million
views
10 million 25 million 50 million and
even 100 million
there's lots of them and and kids are
watching these videos and they're
probably watching them
over and over again the old way toy
manufacturers would do things is they
buy tv which was about 90
of their ad spend and then traditional
pr get on the big morning shows
it's an entirely different formula it's
much harder for toy companies right now
because the formula is so complicated
you have to really take a deep dive into
each platform
am i promoting on twitter am i promoting
on instagram am i promoting on tick tock
what am i doing on youtube you have to
look at every possible social channel
by 2017 big toy brands like mattel had
shifted nearly 50 percent of their
marketing budget
to social platform advertising brands
would help seed videos of their toys
and if they were lucky that could kick
off a wave of creators making their own
content around the product
in 2020 alone tubular labs estimated
that lol related content
had amassed 5.1 billion views
this idea of imitation so when you see
kids playing with product it kind of
excites the same neurons in your brain
that happen when you do it yourself the
more we could show
children uh having this experience
the more kids felt what it would be like
to have it and then wanted to experience
it themselves
you know one of the criticisms of this
whole influencer movement
among kids is that kids are young they
don't understand
what's it necessarily an advertisement
versus real content
and that's a big criticism of this
industry is that a lot of kids are
getting on youtube at young ages
not being supervised by their parents
and just watching these videos
and they don't realize that maybe that
influencer is getting paid by the brand
to do that video
or there's some other compensation and
that you know
blurs the lines for kids as they're sort
of developing and figuring out how to
consume
media questionable advertising concerns
aside
kids youtube creators would take off
channels like ryan's world would grow to
almost 30 million subscribers and a
whole industry formed around them
when we first started working with
influencers they were
very happy to work for free product
you give them the product and they do
something for you then gradually
influencers got smarter and started
you know charging for their services as
they started building a following
now because it is such a big business
the dollars can be significant investing
in big
influencers when spin master
launched one of its new tv series and
associated product
we made it a point to buy
an advertising package with
ryan's world to ensure that we could get
really quick big reach
right away this is an advertisement for
spin master
so from these unboxing videos the
content's gotten a lot more
sophisticated they're creating
narratives around the toys
with voices and meta universes if you
will and it's really engaging content
even more so than the original unboxing
videos for these kids and you know the
content is coming out maybe
once a week or even daily so if you
think about it what they've done is
they've created
basically like a tv show around a toy
it's not unlike what we saw back in the
80s
which was criticized back then by the
way when you had toys like gi joe
turn into an animated series or masters
of the universe or transformers
so we've kind of seen this full circle
now right so back to where we were
content and basically many television
shows created around toys on youtube
kids content on youtube is likely to
face increased regulation in the coming
years
in 2019 the company would agree on a 170
million dollar settlement with the ftc
for serving ads based on personal data
to kids on youtube
youtube would put more emphasis behind
its made for kids platform youtube
kids and each video uploaded to youtube
must be flagged as either
made for kids or not in a statement
outlining changes to the site
youtube would say that responsibility is
our number one priority at youtube
and this includes protecting kids and
their privacy still the site is far less
regulated than traditional television
i do think parents have a better
understanding of
of youtube now and and the new genres
and formats there
that that they didn't prior and they
now notice things like their kid isn't
watching
a toy unboxing that's a commercial for a
toy their kid is watching
other kids play with toys in an
imaginative way
which inspires them to go play with
things in the real world
in an imaginative way in just a few
short years
youtube had caused a transfer of power
from toy and network executives
to nine-year-olds and their families the
kaji family may have started out as toy
reviewers
but now ryan has launched his own line
of toys
a cartoon series he was even a blimp in
the 2020 macy's thanksgiving parade
you or i might think about spider-man or
snoopy but today's kids
see that blimp of ryan and they relate
to him he's the character they want to
grow up with he's
he's the character that they want to
engage with and as we go forward these
influencers are becoming more and more
like big
giant global brands and that has
profound
effects for entertainment going forward
you